we are very excited that oprah is about
to reveal her next highly anticipated
book club selection right here only on
cbs this morning
good morning
uh hey cbs team i'm so excited to be
here with you all to share my next book
club selection the love songs of w.e.b
du voice by award-winning poet honore
fanon jeffers wow may i say this is her
very first novel and it is epic and i
was just enraptured by the lineage and
the story of this modern
african-american family the garfields
who are living in the north but deeply
rooted in the south it's a combination
of historical and modern story i i've
never read anything quite like it it
just consumed me all
790 pages so i am thrilled for you
that ms honore is there to share more
about her epic book which is available
beginning today wherever books are sold
wow
the love songs of w.e.b du bois so get
your copy and then join me as we read
and discuss
this beautiful novel
at oprah's book club on instagram and
facebook thank you cbs this morning
you're welcome oprah poet honore fanon
jeffers received the naacp image award
for outstanding literary work this year
she has published five poetry volumes
before writing as oprah just described
her debut novel and she joins us this
morning good morning to you honore it's
so good to meet you in person i've heard
great great things but let me hold this
let me hold up this book because the
first thing i said to oprah when i got
it i said you know it's close to 800
pages
don't you think that's a lot to ask
readers to do and she said just read it
because i said why is it so long she
goes that is the wrong question to ask
she said just read it and then i started
reading and i called her back and i go i
totally get it i totally get it so bravo
to you i want to talk about the
character in the book the main character
ailee tell us about her i've heard it
described as messi and a firecracker
well ailey pearl garfield is um
the child of bale and jeff garfield and
she is messy she is um
[Music]
you know she's chubby
she's um she'll cuss people out she'll
get them told um she really tells people
what's on her mind but she's also very
brilliant yes and um very
um engaged in
um
reading and thinking and critical
analysis and so i just wanted to um
present someone that wasn't perfect but
was really fascinating for readers you
know oprah said to me that when she read
it it felt like coming home because it
focuses on
trauma unprocessed unprocessed trauma in
your life and how it affects your life
later on could you talk about that
because originally you were thinking
this was going to be a beach read but no
it's certainly far from that
well yes the first thing you know that i
wanted was just a commercial book a
beach read
um something that um my agent could sail
because she really wanted me to write a
novel but i wasn't interested in writing
a novel i only wanted to write short
stories but then what happened is i
began to have these dreams
where um people would come to me in the
dreams african-american
people and particularly women dark brown
skin as the kids say richly melanated um
women and they would talk to me
sometimes i couldn't understand what
they were saying their accents were so
thick and then it took me i would wake
up from the dreams i would write down
um what had been said
and then it took me about probably about
18
months to two years to realize these
were ailee's ancestors and that's when
the whole book changed
honorable change that's an incredible
story i love hearing about the process
of it and on the on that subject how did
you i mean you did an immense amount of
historical research to write a story
about america that begins before america
was called america way before how did
you keep that lyrical
poet's voice in the book when bringing
in all of this history and you call it
love songs
well
one of the things is because i'm a poet
my natural voice is very
much poetic
um there were moments where i was scared
that it would it was too poetic and i
tried to you know strip the poetry out
and my agent sarah burns she was just
really upset
she was like what what did you do yeah
um
and so but in terms of calling it love
songs
it's uh it's a love letter to black
women yeah and again
black women deep brown
black women coily haired kinky haired um
the kind of women that i view as
beautiful
you know um women that look like um
oprah women that look like michelle
obama women that look like viola davis
um you know i wanted again to have a
different story a story that would
celebrate us
in in all our beauty and complexity
honorary i'm i'm fascinated by your
process and i'm fascinated by how these
voices came to you and your dreams
what did you
what did you make of them when you first
started hearing them
um i dream
uh
poems a lot
poetry is like prayer for me
and so
um i'm used to waking up with language
um you know in my spirit in my head and
writing them down
the hardest part was taking what at
first i thought were just long prose
poems
and then making them into a story that's
what took a lot longer
um if i was just going to write a series
of poems
yeah i would have been done with that in
you know 18 months two years but trying
to make sure that these characters were
fully developed and then connecting them
to ailey so that everything comes
together at the end of the book that's
what took a long time
professor jefferson let me just say this
the atlantic says with the love songs of
w.e.b du bois
de voice jeffers has created an opus an
indelible entry into the canon of
contemporary american literature one of
the foundational fictional tests of
black literature worthy of sitting
alongside tony morrison's the bluest eye
ralph ellison's invisible man and
jasmine ward's sing unburied saying
that's a pretty good company and i
understand when oprah called you you
thought that you that you were being
pranked i think that's funny that
happens to her all the time
yeah i did and until she got that that
oprah sound
her voice
and she said this is oprah winfrey
and and then i start and then i say oh
my god
i started crying then i cried i cried
and cried no i've never heard her use
the word in rapture for a book and lady
lee who's on camera three told me this
just now there's a 19-week wait at the
library for your book 19 weeks wait so
congratulations bravo bravo i'm so so
happy for you and i can't wait for
people to read it people of all colors
should read this book thank you
professor jeffries thank you so much the
law thank you miss king i appreciate it
you're welcome you're welcome the love
songs of w.e.b du bois is on sale right
now